it's who were trying to do well in Iowa
by running television commercials and
coming here on occasion is that a
winning strategy you know it hasn't
proven to be historically I mean I was a
state that expects you to be on the
ground they expect to look a candidate
the eyes they expect to be able to make
their own determinations and I think
Iowa New Hampshire both have been
neither one has been all that hospitable
to a candidate who thinks you can write
a check you can go to a TV studio and
then Hatton and somehow win the campaign
this election is about grassroots it's
about really answering the hard
questions and you can't do that from the
safety and security of a TV studio in
the i-95 corridor you need to be sitting
in a pizza ranch looking an Iowa farmer
in the eyes and answering the really
difficult questions and letting him or
her make the assessment whether you're
telling the truth the human scale of
this for people haven't seen it's kind
of a [ __ ] we just left a picha ranch
at that one event you aided a woman who
fainted and you helped a woman look for
her car keys are those two things
required to get elected pressure look at
me people want a real human being and
they wanna that's the value of
interacting in person and and i have to
say actually ironically the media is
helpful in this because many folks in
the media paint this the scary
caricature of me is this you know evil
ogre and then when someone sits down and
we have a chance to visit what the media
has painted is is so different listen
like any human being i have lots of
failings but i don't think i am
particularly crazy or
nastier or me let the record show you
revive the woman but you didn't find the
car keys no but she did find a car keys
which we checked we checked on our
changes are the team was watching ounces
you wouldn't I want to ask you about
some things in the news right now a lot
of turmoil in the Chinese economy and it
is the American economy too intertwined
with the Chinese economy for our own
good well whether it's too intertwined
or not we're in a global economy and
then that's not going to change and in
so from our perspective there's always
going to be shocks to the economic
system worldwide that's not going to go
away and the answer for us is to keep
the American economy as strong as
possible and and right now we're in a
vulnerable position you know I'm
reminded of Bill Clinton's former chief
of staff described the economy as the
prettiest horse and the glue factory
that's not a very good description but
we're we're dependent on China la ways
that we've they bombard loaned us a lot
of money yeah we they're a big trading
partner is there steps you think the
country should take the government
should take to maybe make us less
dependent on what could be a lot of
turmoil in China I'm sure and what we
should be doing it is following the
policies we know work to produce jobs
here the key to job creation is small
business and this is where Washington
gets it wrong when Washington thinks
about business it thinks about big
business the giant corporations that
have lobbyists big business doesn't
create the majority of jobs in the
economy the majority of new jobs in the
economy come from small businesses
two-thirds of them and so I think the
focus needs to be very much on the small
mom and pops of the people starting
things in their garage help us insulate
us from China because if our economy is
booming here at home it gives us the
domestic strength to stand strong and
the two most effective levers that
government can apply to help small
businesses create jobs our tax reform
and regulatory reform and they've proven
over
to work if I'm elected president the tax
burden and the regulatory burden on job
creators and small businesses and
farmers and ranchers will decrease
dramatically and every time we've done
that the result of that has been
incredible economic growth which helps
this country and helps insulate us from
whatever economic shocks might happen
abroad when I see one more about China
Donald Trump proposed tongue the new
york times editorial board a 45-percent
tariffs on goods from China is that a
good idea well I'm a little macys to
talking to the New York Times Editorial
Board I I try to focus on productive
endeavors listen I think just just
hosting a policy question he's proposing
I'm asking to attack him I'm just saying
is that a good idea that economic idea
forty-five percent tariffs on Chinese
goods I think simple protectionism
enacting large tariffs for the sake of a
blocking foreign goods I think
historically that has hurt American jobs
I'll point out a much better approach I
believe it is my tax plan my simple flat
tax is for individuals a ten percent
simple flat tax and for businesses a
16-percent business flat tax and we
eliminate the corporate income tax we
eliminate the death tax we eliminate the
payroll tax we eliminate the obamacare
taxes but the thing that's relevant on
the question of tariffs is the sixteen
percent business flat tax is what's
called border adjustable which means any
goods being exported whether you're a
farmer or Rancher manufacturer are tax
free so you don't pay the sixteen
percent business flat tax that helps
every American farmer and rancher and
manufacturer who's exporting so forty
five percent tariffs on Chinese goods is
not something you'd propose it is not
but the flip side of the business flat
tax is every import pays a 16-percent
business flat tax but it's not a
punitive tariffs it's simply putting
imports on a level playing field so that
American manufacturers can
eat well and effectively that will have
a dramatic result number one it won't
start a trade war it's the same thing
you're up in Asia are doing to us now
and so it doesn't start a trade war you
know if the response is that we see
protective tariffs going up against us
goods that hurts America so this is a
response that enhances American jobs
without hurting our ability to compete
the marketplace